mientras ambas partes hicieron caso
omiso de los llamamientos a un alto al
fuego con motivo del final del ramadán
continuaron los intensos combates
callejeros en Cartoon entre las fuerzas
leales al jefe del ejército sudanés
abdel fatal burján y los que luchan por
su adjunto conocido como gemetti
comandante del poderoso grupo
paramilitar fuerzas de apoyo rápido
miles de civiles arriescan sus vidas
para huir dejar Tun mientras otros se
refugian en casa abandonando los planes
de visitar a la familia para la etapa
final del ramadán
intenté salir de casa por la mañana pero
anoche hubo bombardeos y ahora hay
presencia del ejército sobre el terreno
podría haber combates callejeros Así que
cambió de opinión Cuando mi familia me
instó a no salir
mientras las temperaturas suben hasta
los 40 grados centígrados muchos hogares
están quedando sin agua potable los
médicos han advertido de una catástrofe
ya que más de dos tercios de los
hospitales de la zona en conflicto están
fuera de servicio debido a los combates
Ahora nos encontramos en una situación
en la que está en peligro la
supervivencia de más de 50.000 niños con
desnutrición aguda grave
cuando comienzan los bombardeos o los
bombardeos fuera de los hospitales y
cuando el personal médico tiene que huir
Entonces qué
el programa mundial de alimentos afirma
que la violencia podría asumir en el
hambre a millones de personas más en un
país donde un tercio de la población
depende de su ayuda ese organismo ha
suspendido sus operaciones en Sudán
después de que tres de sus trabajadores
fueran asesinados el sábado